for more than
three months the burmese army has been
bombing
and shelling myanmar's current state
these latest attacks
after the coup it's bad and it could get
worse
have fled their homes due to air strikes
and fighting the free burma rangers is a
humanitarian
movement and organization we are not a
militia we're not part of any of the
armed groups
we are also not pacifists we believe
people have the right to defend their
own lives that's a basic human right
and to defend others karen state is
located in
south eastern myanmar on the border with
thailand
many people living there are now
desperate for aid
this is free burma ranger's account of a
recent mission
most places we work in burma you have to
walk and
it involves river crossings and walking
up and down mountains
we move with everything on our backs or
sometimes with attack animals as well
jets over our head right now i thought
marie bombed earlier today
can hear it day and night
they're on high alert for bombing and
soldiers
here we are in the little bunker i can
hear the aircraft right over us
flying around
and go mommy's reinforcing up this road
so we are
finding another way through with all
these supplies
30 of our rangers have been killed in
service
and those ranges that were caught by the
burma army if they were alive
they were tortured to death and killed
every one of them and so if we were
captured
we could expect death in some areas
rebel groups give them safe passage
don't pass that guy that land mine past
him
we were very close to a burma army camp
and so the local resistance
scouted the road out so that we could
cross this road
safely almost 50 000
people in the states have been displaced
by the fighting
in recent months their villages
are no longer safe this school was
bombed
you see the damage here all the kids
have run away now
this is piece of shrapnel from the
missile that came in
this damage here and there's shrapnel
everywhere
looks like secondary explosions like a
possible cluster bomb just the way
the dispersion and the kind of small
rounds that went in
the damage here school all these school
supplies
and kids notebooks
of the world
all the school supplies the trophies
from different sports and then all this
destruction
koren's ethnic armed forces have been
battling government soldiers for more
than
70 years but violence has surged
since the military seized power in
february
with ginter troops launching air and
ground attacks
this is the blood of a man who was
killed in here
by the airstrike he was wounded he
picked up his son who was injured
came down the stairs this is all his
blood
and took his son to his wife who was in
the trench
gave him to his wife and he died
conditions are very hard some of them
lost family members to the air strikes
or ground attacks
many of them are sick and there's no
school
they're hiding in the jungle now it's a
rainy season so it's psychologically
hard it's emotionally very hard and
physically it's hard
and sicknesses rise in these
circumstances
coming up to the families this place for
the bombing
people are hiding up here in the
mountains from burma army airstrikes
in this spot there are five families
among them the young mother whose
husband died
saving their son from the airstrikes
that child has already shrapnel still in
his head and his neck we couldn't get it
all out
so it makes you feel very sad and very
angry and it's wrong
sky news isn't allowed into myanmar to
verify
all of the stories you've heard we asked
myanmar's military for a comment
it hasn't responded
the burmese army has previously accused
free burma rangers of training and
assisting armed rebels
the group insists their focus is helping
those
in need our teams go to give help hope
and love and not to fight
however they can defend the people
they're with
how did we get involved here we were
invited by people in burma saying please
come and help us
and as long as the people want us
however long that takes we're in
all the way
allah